the fourth turning is a cult text that
is embraced widely on the American right
it's all about the notion that American
history ignore all previous human
history ignore everything that's outside
of America and then oversimplify until
you can make a pattern from 1776 to
today of significant crisis and it's
true that about every 80 years there
appears to be a major crisis in this
particular case this crisis is entirely
being foisted on us we are doing things
like the web telescope like Landers on
Mars we are capable of doing absolutely
amazing things and there is a broad
front assault on our confidence and the
fourth turning is part of it